We Begin here with our top story this
morning students at Von tobel Middle
School in the Northeast Valley they'll
return to class after a staff member was
shot on school property yesterday the
school was placed on an immediate hard
lockdown the students went home early
Lauren and Grady is live from campus
this morning with the latest details
Lauren good morning to you
good morning you guys yes students are
starting to
have starting to arrive on campus now
like you said after that that incident I
talked to one student who shared a
little bit more about the victim that
campus monitor that was shot he's the
student says that that person is a very
well-liked outgoing person on the campus
and he described The Hectic scene that
happened yesterday now again this all
happened here at the Von Noble excuse me
Von tobel middle school now new
admission for our 8 news now
investigator says the victim again is a
campus Monitor and is expected to
survive two sources close to the
investigation say that a school monitor
may have been hit by a stray bullet
fired during an unrelated incident the
shooting prompted two school lockdowns
again
I was scared and we heard like knocking
from like the police
and handle like moving and once they got
in I was wondering if my sister was also
safe
so far Metro has not revealed any
suspect info and I have put a requests
with both CCSD and Metro for more
information on both the suspect and on
the victim if you know anything you are
encouraged to call Crime Stoppers the
number right there on your screen and
you can stay Anonymous we're going to
keep on this story this morning but for
now live at in Northeast Las Vegas
Lauren negretti 8 news now back to you
guys
right now we know you'll be watching
that we'll be watching those
developments this morning Clark County
School District police do say that they
are aware of some false threats
circulating on social media in a
statement police say they're working to
identify where those threats are coming
from authorities warning the public
anyone making false threats could be
arrested of course we're going to be
following this story closely throughout
the day as it continues to develop you
can get those free updates by
downloading our app it is free eight
news now it's in the App Store as well
as Google Play